the word artistic integrity brings back
a memory I my second film was life at
the top which I shot in England with
Laurence Harvey and gene Simmons and
there was a screening of the film for
Philip Epstein and Julius Epstein they
were they were the two great writers
wrote Casablanca and many great films of
the 40's and 50's and the producer was a
friend of those and they invited them to
see the film and I sat next to Philip
I'd Epstein active after the screening
he said to me Kent he said it's your
you're gonna have wonderful career as a
director I predict death from your mouth
to God's ear and and he said so and you
you'll be you'll fight for the artistic
integrity of your film with all your
might and your mind and your soul you'll
protect it against people who want to
interfere with it but can I give you a
word of advice there's two areas
don't bother wasting your energy because
you'll never win this battle with
distributors I say then what are those
you said titles and endings and and it
happened it happens I lost over this
film waken frightened made in australia
united artists when they distributed it
in New York changed the title to outback
and he said oh that sounds like a
National Geographic documentary
what's the matter is waking Frank they
said sounds like a Hitchcock film I said
that's bad but I didn't win that fight
it came out as I'm back even though I I
thought I thought it was not I thought I
didn't it was a very commercial title
even what does it mean out back you know
a back where out back of your house but
I'm waking frightened was what the film
was about a guy who suddenly discovers
wakes up and sees what the person he's
capable being he doesn't like what he
sees anyway No
the same right with that I mean what
what did you expect upon the release of
waking fright in 1971 and and now what
do you expect 40 years later to being
released and right now well when I made
the film in 1970 in Australia and and I
thought the film was beautifully written
and well realised them and however when
it was when when it was open it opened
in Australia I think this reading is
kind of responded badly to what they
thought was a kind of a unsympathetic
depiction of the Aussie male scurrilous
and so nobody it didn't although I've
got very good reviews from the
Australian film critics nobody came but
the picture had a certain kind
reputation but commercially did little
then Dennis I went to the Cannes Film
Festival and the first was thrilling for
a young director like myself to be
invited to go to this iconic Film
Festival the dream of every filmmaker to
be invited and of course the French
loved the film the French love that kind
of men under existential stress etc and
it's the only country in the world that
was successive ran for nine months on
the shelves of ESA in Paris nine months
rent and then yeah artists released it
in America and the film was they they
said Ted they didn't believe in the
phone girl
they said Americans are not gonna come
and see this film it's and that there
really really will be offended by that
that rather heinous massacre of
kangaroos which was the climax of the
film so as a result when they put no
money in the advertising and film on
surfer there was no publicity when it
opened it opened in a small cinema on
the east side of New York on a Sunday
night in the heavy blizzard and they
were right nobody came is it
told you nobody would come
there's nothing like distributors for
self-fulfilling prophecies by not
spending any money at birth they
guarantee that nobody would come nobody
knew this existence even but and so that
was it for the film it there was not
even any prints for anybody to see it
and 25 years ago by the film was
originally had been financed by half by
Australian company and half way a
company called group W films and I'll
shear the Westinghouse who had a a chain
of television stations in New England
and northeast and so they started to
make films for their their television
network but but films didn't succeed so
a group W went bankrupt and that's
always death for filming the film the
negative falls in the hands of creditors
they don't to do it that they use it
maybe for paying off some other debt and
it's passed around and the film was
worthless as far as they were concerned
and they filmed it open to various
places have not taken any money I mean I
mean you never artists after the fiasco
in New York
did it they were supposed to open all
across the country they didn't they
yanked it and that was that
so 25 years it was buys I'm when one of
these early introduced it was oppressed
by some Film Society that said where is
that film I wake in fright that was
rather rather a good film he liked to
show it to my students so he tried to
find it and of course it disappeared and
then they went to Sydney when they went
to London where the filming process at
Pinewood not there and he couldn't
believe it rather kind of I he described
it an exaggerated fashion as a national
disaster because because it was a say
quintessential Italian film and then and
then they editor
Toni Buckley he loved the film
and thought it was a seminal film a
seminal Australian film so he set out at
his own expense try to find it and he
traveled in between his jobs for
thirteen years between jobs he jumped
into a plane go to London go to winter
and neighs they said now I was sent to
America after you
he went to Dublin because he heard
rumors that there was a print in Dublin
but it turned out to be not the case not
usable print anyway and he went to New
York and looked around in 13 years
finally he found the negative in a
warehouse in Pittsburgh in two huge
boxes and it had big red levers on the
box for destruction heavy arrived one
week later the incinerators of the
negative of the film of disappeared
forever so I think that story intrigued
a lot of people it's been Australia was
huge that found this thing and the
Australian archives come and got the
film then the negative once they asked
they found the negative but it was
useless
it was scratched come on damaged faded
and this another extraordinary man who
loved the film and worked at deluxe
laboratories in Sydney called emphysema
the next two years of his life in his
spare time he digitally restored the
film frame by frame produced a negative
which produced a positive was
unbelievable colours and clarity
intensity and that that copied the films
the one is going to be shown here in Los
Angeles and across the country next next
Friday October 19th and the new word
cinema that so and I think that and this
time the film was released in Australia
and people flocked to it it was
extraordinary and now I just now it was
opened opened in New York and people who
sold out every night and got
unbelievable reviews so I was couldn't
believe it forty years after we made
this film it's getting great reviews
some people are talking to see it or had
it failed totally in the beginning
so it's been it's good I got it have to
tell you I've gotta tell you David this
is one of no it's extraordinary couple
of weeks of my whole life
I've never heard of any such thing in
the whole history of filmmaking the film
succeeds 40 years have to be made it how
do you wrap your mind around that I
can't I just
I'm disbelieving I'm incredulously
that's just incredible no but it's been
a thrilling experience I mean late blade
in my life's to have such a New Yorker
you